[Music]
my name is chanya linghu
i am developing new technologies for
detecting the symphony of cellular
activities in the brain
the brain uses many different kinds of
simultaneously interacting signals to
function
all of these signals work together in
harmony in the healthy brain
to understand this harmony we need to
measure these signals at the same time
up to now most scientists could only
image one or two signals at a time
because the number of signal reporters
that can be used together
is limited to the number of available
colors on the microscope
we have just developed a new technology
that allows us to record multiple
signals in real time
regardless of the color of reporters we
call it signaling reporter islands
or series for short it works by
spatially separating the signal
reporters
into small islands throughout the cell
first
we engineered signal reporters to
self-assemble into serial islands in the
cell
next we record individual cellular
signals by capturing the light
emitted from individual series islands
then
we fix the cells and perform immune
staining to identify distinct tags bound
to each of the different reporters
finally we attributed the light
emissions to the corresponding cellular
signals
according to the immunosame results we
measured five signals together
in the first paper and we're working to
increase the number to tens of
individual signals
our hope is that by measuring multiple
aspects of the cellular symphony in
parallel
we can pinpoint the exact differences
between healthy and diseased brains
and provide insights into new treatments
[Music]